if you remember last time we developed
this idea here now you may recall how
did we get this
what did we do to end up with that
statement where did it come from
it came from some weird tomfoolery with
chain rule did they're right
DVR DX and DX agenda and so on and so on
okay you put over together eventually
you get back to here okay that proof is
vitally important by the way it is a
confusing proof it's not long but you
need to be able to reproduce it so get
back to where your notes on that if you
like but the real point is number one
because it comes with chain rule this is
always true with regards to motion it's
not just about simple harmonic motion ok
so what I'm gonna do is think about some
of the ways you could use it and some of
the things that this means what we do
apply it to simple how many version
which we started doing last time but we
created about we kind of stops short so
here's an example you've got this
equation this differential equation okay
and here's some information that they
provide about what the particle is doing
here the two questions he expressed v
square as a function of X as a function
of displacement can you do that
okay can we do that secondly can you
verify this this statement that you're
going to develop a party can you verify
it not using the displacement equations
but the time equation can you off the
information that's been given to you
have a displacement time equation and a
velocity time equation you should take
you know your way around time
displacement at time velocity okay so
there you go there's a set up how are we
going to do this where shall we start if
what I'm after is v square as a function
of X and what I've got is this what are
your suggestions
well the whole point is about using this
right okay
so anywhere you see acceleration X
double dot okay you can substitute in
for DX half P Square ad where you see it
okay and if it's convenient to you
you should write I want these words
they're gonna be squids here that's okay
one you alright so here we go cut it the
derivative with respect to X of half V
squared okay
that's equal to minus four X slip-ups
okay I want V squared on its own right
so integrate with respect to X and that
gives you this hmm
power goes up divided what do you get
negative 2x squared cool plus a constant
that's nice
I would be squared don't I be square so
that's actually if I multiply through
you get this okay so this is good but I
have a constant flying around I don't
want to constant play around how do I
get rid of it I've got conditions don't
on initial conditions Yeah right some
stationary Jihu 0 V equals 0 x equals 6
these are all concurrently true okay so
which of them am I going to use get X
because I don't have any time in my
equations right good so let's take these
two values okay I can say when x equals
6 or we're really that's where I am okay
and I know how fast I'm going at that
point so substitute that it you're gonna
get 0 equals negative 4 times 36 that's
144 big 944 so
the other side.now could work out what C
is but I don't need to because I
actually want to see don't i okay so
moving up over here
therefore now I have V squared minus 4x
squared plus 144 there you go done V
squared as a function of displacement
that's part A Part B how do I verify a
result like this doing this hmm how'd
you go about it verify suppose it's the
same proof or sure so you've got a left
hand side the right hand side right now
I want to show that bit equal to the
same thing how we're gonna do that where
should I start I want to have
displacement and velocity in terms of x
somehow right this isn't really going to
help me is it there's no there's no this
is a timeless kind of situation just
talks about where and how fast okay so
how do I introduce time in what
information am I going to use what's the
clevis of all this information was
figured out that recipe just look at
this just look at that tells you a lot
doesn't it okay what does it tell you
right away what things could we see just
from that okay it's simple harmonic
motion right so what's the what is the
differential equation for all simple
harmonic motion equations it's a minus N
squared X right well therefore you know
exactly what n is and is equal to 2
right okay that's a start just remind me
what's in tell you what's that about
that's about the period the frequency
isn't it
I guess that tells you that the
frequency would be PI seconds yet you
pile on it
that's good yeah hold on a second if
that's what it is
I need a couple of other piece of
information right what are the other
bits of information that go into a
displacement equation I've got an what
else is there
is a right amplitude we can I find an
amplitude of this situation and put
suits there I'll give you a clue this
doesn't tell you about outputs you
because it just tells you about
frequency that's all the information
that's in there it puts you is hidden
somewhere in here where is it
amplitude is six how do you know it's
simple harmonic right it's stationary at
six right in other words where is simple
harmonic where is it stationary at the
extremities right at the extremities so
this obviously is one of them right
question for you how do you know which
extremity this is like is it the top one
or the bottom one is it this six there's
a verse 6 there okay is it like is it
like this or is it like this you can
tell the information is all there in
that first line
as a bit sneaky I told you the only
piece of information in this equation is
differential equation I said the only
piece of information was the period
right but that's not entirely true is it
there's something else implied in there
right this question is about whether I'm
asking that where the centre of motion
is right this will tell you where the
center market is where's this inhibition
it's the origin if it was in the origin
what equation would I get it would be X
minus X naught wouldn't there okay you
see how much information is packed in
there if you know how to read it okay
good so that means x equals 6 is our
extremity okay and we're centering
around the origin okay hmm that's good
that's good that means a equals 6
but I still don't know a couple of
things well maybe one thing really
you've got a you've got in is its I know
cause why is it cause haha it begins and
extremity and sign does not begin at an
extremity it begins at the origin right
great because okay so that's all the
information you need right x equals a 6
cos n t2 t bigger there's my
displacement equation okay you see how
we develop that it's all nestled in
there if you know how to interpret it
properly okay if that's my displacement
equation what's my velocity equation
negative cos cos turns into negative 12
sine good okay now there's my X days
might be here is the result I am trying
to prove do you think it'll be easy to
go from right to left or left to right
oh that's it I personally think right to
left because my brain my brain tends to
go complex to simple I don't like going
simple to complex that's the adding add
and add and subtract the same thing and
then have some magical factorization I
prefer to have something that's messy
and then I know how to tidy it up okay
so I'm gonna do that right inside this
minus 4 there's X right so I'm gonna
have 36 cos squared 2t okay
that's minus 4x squared all right yeah
right you're staring and funny don't do
something wrong that's okay
plus 144 yeah cool 4 times 36 I already
know what that is that's also 144 so I
can take 144 out okay this order really
should be 1 minus cos squared shouldn't
it
put the subtraction at the end that's
144 I'm not gonna write it up in 44 I'm
gonna write minus 12 squared can you see
why you see where I'm going right sine
squared 2t it go there's B squared okay
they go so what did we gain from that
what was the point you give a situation
okay this business here about using this
DX hat B squared right it's tremendously
useful for actually developing this kind
of thing off which you can read other
pieces of information okay but as a
particular line I'm interested in this
line here okay
it's interesting to me if I factorize
that a little bit the reason why it's
interesting my because then what obvious
to you have a look and take a factor of
four thangka now have a look at this V
squared equals equals this okay
these numbers we don't believe in
coincidences mathematics right these
numbers seem suspiciously familiar right
we spent Part B trying to work out what
they were okay but if I factorize that
you wouldn't be able to see it straight
away
right for of course is just true square
right and 36 is 6 squared in other words
there you go there's your N and there's
your efforts use okay is that always
true you felt what true can we prove or
is it just a coincidence how would you
go about doing it